um Liz
I'll start with you and your reaction to what we heard from Donald
uh there
this claim that he will protect women whether they like it or not
and I'm going to do it whether the women like it or not
might be the most truthful thing that Donald  has ever said
Donald has created a new cast system in America
where pregnant women have become the untouchables
and this is not my opinion
these are the words of an expert in the field
Sarah Rosenbaum who's talked to Pro Publica for their stories
that you shared in the previous segment
who is saying that er
doctors are refusing to touch these pregnant women
and so what we have is not just a handful of women
what we have is thousands of women not being treated in
you know going through one of the most dangerous things that you can go through
as a woman which is childbirth right
childbirth is actually far more uh
safe than getting an aborshhhh
and we're not talking again about a few
just in Texas alone where two women have died of these abortion bans
we know that the amount of pregnant women who are dying in childbirth
has increased by 56%
and so these politicians are creating a new hierarchy where they're at the top
and the women who birth them
and the women who will birth the next generation of Americans are at the bottom